we have a story from the post-millennial
and just let me read the title first for
before my proposal four Iranian special
interest aliens apprehended by border
patrol attempting to cross into us in
October two Lebanese citizens were also
arrested in Eagle Pass last week all
right new rule if you're going to deploy
US military forces into a region in
Conflict you must lock down your borders
oh that's a good idea I think it's a
great idea that why wouldn't you do that
that why wouldn't you secure your
borders even outside of well it's like
if you knew that there was turmoil in
your neighborhood you'd probably lock
your front door right why why are we
defending the borders in Ukraine and
defending the borders in Israel but
we're not defending our own bord no no
our borders get to stay open because
it's okay if our citizens suffer we
can't let citizens in other countries
suffer though that would be bad are they
coming in on fan boats have you seen
repor some reporting have them all over
how cool would it be if they're coming
in like hovercrafts you ever see those
they Glide over the water like the air
pressure and the floats hilarious
they reporting from the Darion Gap it's
like these long kayak looking type boats
mhm yeah what if they were like throwing
grappling hooks over trees and Swinging
across the river if that's the case then
let Let's Go lit them in if that's the
case that is unless they have close the
border yeah what if it's that cool
Co but if they paraglide over the border
wait wait what if they swung from a tree
and then when they released they did
back flip I think you guys don't
understand no illegal immigration no
matter how cool even if they're anime
superheroes I also love theatrics but
ultimately I'm not going to give an
exception for the best entry the Cirus
La Brigade they're just like they way
under the Border it's meritocracy like
like Tim said and our country is founded
on meritocracy so I mean it checks out
it checks out okay but in all
seriousness uh our border is porous and
busted we're deploying troops to go
protect other people's borders and we
have potential war war time threats to
this country Iranian special interest
aliens and it's not saying overt
terrorists or anything like that do you
want actually do you know the story liby
I mean it's your your write it today you
know I didn't write that one actually
you know everything that goes up on post
millennial every day you to know
everything so here's the point yeah as
lindsy Graham is threatening to bomb
Iran does it look we want to be very
careful about who we're letting into the
country after one of our Senators
threaten to bomb their country right
yeah so the real risk is not we're not
even talking about economic or whether
it's cool how they enter that that's
obviously a big joke the threat is Yo
are we letting spies into this country
to attack us yes we do that all the time
this is the thing like we under the
guise of being able to say this is a
humanitarian issue we need to be nice we
just let anyone enter so why would
another country not be like we'll just
send some military hm we just will send
a spy because you can get through the
Border this is go ahead no I'm sorry oh
I I can rant about this all day long
this is a different this is an addition
to the 151 individual on the FBI Terror
watch list who have been admitted to the
country since um Biden took did they say
that they lost track of like 24
terrorists they lost track of a lot of
people they've lost track of children
who are being now like sold into
Domestic and Sexual slavery absolutely
but that way they get to be here when it
happens like I I just don't understand
this argument for why anyone would
benefit from an open border everyone
suffers and the Biden Administration
passes off is like these actually over
70,000 special interest aliens that they
have
encountered what does that mean special
interests are we talking about Terror
threats well let's see what it means
what because I know that we we we'
specifically talked about people a legal
alien from a nation that either promotes
terrorist activity Harbors terrorists or
poses a possible security threat so what
that is these are people who president
Donald Trump said we're not going to let
any of these people into the country and
he was called islamophobic for oh yeah
was was this the Muslim band yeah it oh
it's the Muslim band it was the Muslim
band well was a Muslim band Plus North
Korea and Venezuela today North Korea
capital of the world the disantis
campaign started being like when is
Trump going to talk about what he would
do about terrorist illegal immigrants
and it's like what you mean how about
what he did he doesn't have to talk
about what he would do he and he did
things when he was in office he kept
people out no no he recently did he he
posted a meme of crocodiles and today
also in a
m yeah GRE Abbott's like please send the
crocodiles I don't know if the
crocodiles could survive if they could
they just be there already would ruin
vacationing in the Gulf honestly a few
crocodiles would just Stave this off we
know to stay away from the water in
Florida like Ben bencho made a great
Point uh earlier about he said the West
doesn't need to commit suicide to
protect refugees you might want to pay
attention to who you're letting into
your country it doesn't mean we blame
citizens and civilians in Conflict he
was like we're not going to blame this
the civilians in in in Palestine but
we're not going to open the door just
let everyone come in the Arab countries
the Arab countries aren't letting in
these refugees Egypt's not Egypt's not
you know and also there's no reason that
we should you have what's his name jabal
jbal Bowman in New York saying that we
should take in Palestinian refugees from
Gaza the the fire alarm P trust a guy on
on that who doesn't even know what a
fire alarm well I frankly would probably
not trust anyone from Brooklyn on there
to take from the and she can say that
because she's from New York she lived in
Brooklyn it's not a hate crime so aren't
there standards for Asylum and they're
just like rubber everybody instead of
like being like no you don't meet the
requirement for Asylum so maybe they
should just start enforcing rules that
exist to combine the previous segment
with this segment we don't have enough
people to fight in our armies and so we
import all these illegal immigrants and
then we say that's right that's right
hey you want citizenship all you got to
do is fight for us I we did it before in
Civil War the
Irish but but it it is common they offer
non-citizens a path citizenship by
serving in the armed forces true that's
pretty I mean that's not just an
American thing that's a classic thing
throughout history that Nations have
done isn't that how n like like didn't
Rome do something like that collapsing
did yeah well we did that in the
Revolutionary War I believe that Civil
War well the Revolutionary War was
French intervention the the crown had
the mercenaries French right right right
they had like the Hess I remember that
story we can't ask people who came here
illegally to become citizens you guys
are crazy that would be ridiculous I'm
not on board with this plan either I
think that we should probably I think
that's the policy huge levels of
deportations and just be like no you're
done like this is not going to work out
entire Rosevelt hotel and just like move
out deportation but to Ukraine I just
think the Biden Administration doesn't
want to offer citizenship and they don't
want to offer a p like they like that
there is an ilal what's going on is it's
not that they don't want to offer
citizenship they do want to offer
citizenship they're just going to do all
of this incrementa incrementally they're
doing it slowly just one one little tiny
step at a time so that the next one
seems inevitable and then the next thing
you know we have 5 million new citizens
because they had an amnesty didn't
Reagan do an amnesty they're going to
have like an agreement where it says
like you know sign up for the US armed
forces or go fight in Ukraine and you
will earn citizenship and there will be
like an asteris next to it then at the
bottom of the page it'll be like see
adendum 5e which is not attached to this
contract and then when you search the
like the the paperwork online it'll be
like citizen of Ukraine right I'm okay
with offering illegal immigrants off uh
citizenship in Ukraine that seems fine
to me uh are what what if what if the I
mean honest question I still think it's
probably bad but what if the US was like
we're going to take all the illegal
immigrants and send them to go fight in
Ukraine well does a does one country
people would stop coming yeah I think
they would I think zalinsky would be mad
because he'd be like no you haven't
trained them properly and now I have
this population of people who don't
really know how to fight and it's kind
of an ethn State you know what are we
supposed to say well but you got to you
got to just do you got to take the uh
the the Soviet approach which was I
might add appropriated by zap branagan
in the future in Futurama as a joke
where you just send wave after wave of
your own men to die and eventually
overwhelm the opposing force and I'm not
kidding that's literally the Soviet
method that's what they've done every
time yeah the Soviets just like
effective just take a bunch of
lowquality garbage and just smash it in
that direction isn't that what China
does too basically yeah and then the
Nazis in World War II were like we want
the best technology the premium and then
doing yeah and then when it blows up you
have you have like tanks they're really
great and then eventually one goes down
the Russians were like mass produced the
worst possible tank they're now they're
making they've turned some of their
factories over to like full tank
manufacturing jeez they did that they
did that months and months ago in fact
yeah it's true I think I think we
covered that at human events.com look
with with these stories that we're
getting these these horror horror
stories like the guy who killed the
six-year-old kid the kid died right the
kid died that guy looks like a total
crazy man
too I I think we're going to he was he
was a landlord was the landlord really
oh I'm being very bigoted that was the
opposite he wasn't Not only was he not
homeless but he owned more home yeah he
could have voted during the colonial
period I think I think we're going to
see some kind of like major terror
attack in the next year I believe I
agree with you what they're what they're
doing right now it's kind of a process
that they use to capture different
countries it's demoralization
destabilization crisis and normalization
and usually they kind of do it in order
they're like just demoralize everybody
and then they destabilize everybody and
then they create a chaos and and then
they normalize it but what we're seeing
America do is throw it all throw it all
down and see what sticks so they're
normalizing parts of the chaos and
they're demoralizing everybody to
destabilize them while they're
destabilized they more demoralization
and it's just and that's why Everything
feels so chaotic because it is we feel
like we're moving in fast forward it
does feel very very quick it feels like
weeks take months you know I can't
believe it's mid October already y
That's crazy we like we go to Miami for
a week it's like 80 degrees outside
we're skating is so hard we come back
from Miami and now it's 40 45 Dees that
was a great show by the way congrats was
a terrific event we're thinking we're
thinking we're going to do uh Pittsburgh
in March Pittsburghs because it's so
easy to just drive there it isy to drive
there I watched somebody lose like
$199,000 at a blackjack table in casinos
are in Pittsburgh Tim we can go casinos
everywhere Vegas I watched a guy lose
like 50 Grand in 10 minutes and he
didn't seem to care and I'm just like oh
this guy seemed like he was getting uh
increasingly angry but who really looked
upset was his wife who just like looked
terrified that was a scary moment she's
like this is not a fun vacation to
Pittsburgh this is not great thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at
timcast.net
him